did you take your sats while you were on
lsd while you were high on acid i did
why did you do that because i forgot
that they were the next day
[Laughter]
and and in your special
is willie nelson in the special and you
get high with him yeah is his weed now
you're not a weed person i mean i've
smoked plenty of wheat i'm not a weird
person in the fact that like i have it
on me but willie nelson it seems to me
as like a weed expert almost yeah
where were you when you smoked weed with
willy nils on his bus i was so high how
much weed did you smoke
you know just a couple joints but like a
couple of drugs that's a couple of hits
of a couple joints but
you know it's incredibly difficult as
you know like to talk to someone in
trying to be the interviewer when you're
impaired do you get paranoid on pot no
not usually i mean if i smoke a lot yeah
i could and is willie's weed
very uh potent yeah it is right coming
out with his own line of weed right yeah
first of all i couldn't i was so high
that i was just looking at him thinking
i hope he [ __ ] says something else
because i'm like i don't know what to
say
i couldn't think of any questions this
is some interview and i was just so
stoned that i just thought oh this is
going to be a disaster when you watched
it back do you look as stoned as you
felt in other words did you hold it
together enough yeah people think
they're holding it together did you how
did it look to you i don't ever think
i'm holding it together i know that like
and i don't usually like spin out but i
wasn't i just yeah i look high is the
interview a lot of silence no because
it's quick i mean it's like four or five
minutes i guess i don't really know
about
but no it's not a lot of signs somehow i
filled the gap but i what i was thinking
was
[ __ ] i hope he answers this question in
like a long form
yet he was barely answering questions
because he's high too yeah and he
doesn't talk a lot he can't think of
anything to say either right so two
losers wouldn't have been great if you
two had done ayahuasca and you both [ __ ]
your pants during the interview wouldn't
that be awesome yeah
you